we have got more breaking news this time
on BP Bonnie Quinn has the headlines
that's right Stephanie BP is rising in
European trading up almost four percent
and in premarket trading here as well
almost five percent this after we're
hearing the pp is settling federal and
state claims for up to eighteen point
seven billion dollars over the Gulf oil
spill the companies saying the payment
will be spread out over 18 years now the
dividend will be unchanged by the
agreement but the pack does resolve the
largest liabilities from the accident if
we look into the details 5 Gulf Coast
states are going to receive about 4.9
billion dollars over the 18 years
another 2.2 billion dollars to the
federal government over that time now PP
says the cumulative pre-tax charge is
going to be about 10 billion dollars
more at the end of q1 up from 40 3.8
billion dollars there so the statement
from VP CEO Dudley saying it provides
clarity and that's giving the stocks and
buoyancy this morning